the Joe Rogan experience you ever talk
to win half I don't win do you know
where absolutely yeah yeah I'm doesn't
he doesn't give a [ __ ] if you breathe
out of your nose your mouth
just breathe man I know I know he
doesn't get crazy I love that guy he's
comedy no I have I've had a few I've had
women I've had a few we've had a few
experiences let's just put that way but
we've had him at it we've had him at a
couple of experiences and I've done some
stuff with whim I've known win for like
four or five years now maybe maybe a
little longer so he'll he come usually
when he was in town I think the last
time maybe when you when you saw him he
came he comes to visit so I get him I if
I usually when I go with women easily
translate for him when he goes to one of
his classes I'm usually like trying to
understand so I have to say sometimes
I'll be with somebody they'll be like
what do you say I'll be like what he
means is take a deep breath here he is a
character the guy went to [ __ ] the
top of Everest barefoot oh yeah oh yeah
I almost lost his toes - yeah yeah yeah
no he goes yeah well he's he's his art
actually is to mow is is AB is a
derivative of to mow and I'm not sure if
you know what Cuomo is but to mow is a
Himalayan breathing technique that the
that the the monks have that they were
they they have this one thing where they
dry sheets so they have this thing the
ceremony where they go at night in the
Himalayas when it's frozen and snow and
the guy sits there and they put wet
sheets wet blankets on them and they
breathe and get their bodies so hot that
they dry the blankets and then the guy
that can dry the most blankets at the
end of the night is the is like the guy
you know but it's a yeah yeah and it's
called to mow and it's a you can go
online and look it up but to mow is a is
a Himalayan breathing technique that
that that was never exposed to
Westerners big until just as of recently
but the whims whims work is a derivative
of of - mo but knows breathe it's all
about nose breathing mmm it's all about
nose breathing and when you understand
the science of it but
he's right about getting people to just
breathe because people are not breathing
then we just had in fact we had another
belissa
what sir I want to say it's a Russian
name but but she has a great book she
trains fire fire and police and military
breathing we just had her we did an X PT
in Miami about a week two weeks ago and
and she came as a guest speaker and we
and was working on really trying to
create more volume and then our a lot of
people's rib cages aren't moving and so
they have a whole you know there's ways
to try to increase your movement of your
rib cage your rib cage you'd actually
open like you you can take a tape and
measure your rib cage when you're fully
exhaled and then when you inhale it
should expand like you know three inches
or more for you to be really optimum ly
breathing and a lot of people I mean
part of it has to do with the whole
six-pack abs and what's aesthetically
pleasing but meanwhile when you have a
real nice set of six-pack abs your you
don't you're not able to diaphragmatic
ly breathe you're not able to use your
diaphragm you're not using your
diaphragm without that yeah because
you're you you're the tightness isn't
allowing the diaphragm to push down the
diaphragm and the belt and the pelvic
floor actually squeeze your organs
together and and that is actually
massaging the organs which influences
your digestion and everything and the
deals with a bunch of acid reflux and a
bunch of other things but when the when
the when that's the ABS are so tight
that that the that the stomach can
expand the organs can't push this belly
out then you then then you have a
limitation in your in your brand then
the ribs aren't moving I mean it's just
the guys are gonna hear this and go good
I'm gonna stay fat I don't need a
six-pack well but but no but but I
actually if you're really using your
lungs you you can you know strengthen
your core in a way that you'll get core
you could have six-pack abs and not have
core stability like so you know I mean
and you know this I mean when you look
at a lot of not every single great
fighter is just ripped know some of the
best ones ever not ripped at all or
Fedor exactly so let's talk about that
for four
a example of you know that aesthetic
isn't always function right right and oh
and of course we you know the mind is
always ahead of everything I don't care
what the car looks like if the got no
motor doesn't do anything so it's the
body only goes where the brain tells it
but the fact is is that that you see
some of the best athletes when you look
at certain athletes you're not like
they're not the physical specimens that
you've ever seen you're like that that
guy is the most ripped and shredded a
lot of times those guys get knocked out
yeah you see the guy come on you just go
this guy's gonna kill this guy and then
you just get you know annihilated by the
guy that looks maybe not quite sure
that's hard right right part of his
genetics max Holloway is perfect example
Hawaiian guy yeah he's not like shredded
I mean he's strong yeah obviously but he
looks more like a swimmer yeah yeah WA
and you you might find that his
breathing he might he might have better
air volume because at the end of the day
a lot of its about oxygen cardio yeah
and Max's cardio is off the charts
exactly so he's getting more movement
out of there I mean you know again we've
created these you know aesthetic things
in our culture like Oh six-pack ABS a
sign of this and done it up but when you
look at real breath work and how the
diaphragm works and how the ribs expand
you realize is like where none of us are
really doing it right you know and you
can actually create more volume you know
you said you like cordyceps mushrooms
yes well those are actually a
vasodilator those helps help you absorb
oxygen you those can up your vo2 max
right there's only a couple things that
you can how to increase your vo2 max but
cordyceps is one of them pieces beats
another one you can create more volume
by expanding your lungs so by opening
the ribcage in creating more room that
can create um promote your vo2 max now
when people are hearing this and they're
hearing breath work folks who have never
done anything like that they don't they
really don't understand what you're
saying like what do you mean by breath
work like give us an example of like a
protocol well I mean a real simple I
mean they do it in pranayama they have
it in apnea there's a thing called
holotropic breathwork really is is when
you isolate the breathing system and you
know the simplest way and that's why wim
says hey I don't give a [ __ ] how you
breathe just breathe
yeah yeah so you know like will do a
breath routine and we'll sit somebody
down and we'll say okay breathe like
you're running breathe like you're
running and we'll tell the guy breathe
like he's running another I go that's a
slow run buddy like breathe like you're
running like you know like like anytime
you need any movement in any air in and
out is gonna is a form of breath work
right and especially when you isolate
the system and you're not doing it
because of an activity the fact is that
when you use that system and you work it
and you're not detracting from it by
doing an exercise if you're doing the
assault bike where your arms are working
and your legs are working so all the
oxygen that you're absorbing is going
into your arms and legs when you're
isolating you just do the breathing
alone now the oxygen is going into that
system and that system is gonna develop
and get better then when you do your
assault bike after you develop that
system so we'll isolate breath work and
we'll just do it alone well whether
we're doing you know whether we're doing
breath holes we're doing some kind of
apnea breath work which is you know we
can do a pattern where you're doing like
you you hold for 30 seconds and then you
breathe in for 15 and then you breathe
out for 15 then you hold again then you
go in and out and hold in and out and
hold
that's one pattern another pattern is in
hold out hold in hold out hold in hold
out like you know again those are theirs
you know and then there's pranayama
apnea holotropic there's just some where
you're oxygenating the system where you
know like Wims would be where you just
get that rhythm going and do that for
five minutes and people know about I
feel lighted and I go yeah because you
haven't had oxygen like on your head do
you haven't had oxygen in your system
like that right so again a conscious
bringing consciousness to your breath
we're not just walking along in life
like not thinking about breathing mm-hmm
that's the beginning of breath work just
awareness of hey I need
[Music]
you know I need to need to breathe in
and out I stay conscious yeah and that's
a big one with martial arts you see in
jiu-jitsu with beginners when they first
start sparring for the first time they
panic and they have shallow breath and
you got to tell us okay stop right now
just breathe oh yes breathe
oh yeah well miter fight yeah fighter
flight but it's interesting how they
can't get a deep breath
yeah they hyperventilate yeah well you
put somebody in the ice for the first
time that has oh yeah that's the
craziest want to see it that's an
instantaneous I can't breathe oh yeah
but you eventually learn well the system
the system turned that's actually an
involuntary response to get out mm-hmm
right strike you you have the option so
you should exercise that option that's
it response that's your that's your
subconscious mind protecting the organ
organisms like yeah this in your body
intuitively knows this is dangerous
environment get out and so that reaction
is to get you to get out when you when
you make a conscious effort to not leave
that environment then the body goes okay
you're not gonna get out okay well now
organize I'll bring the blood to the
organs I'll adjust everything I'll boost
your hormones and so and then pretty
soon you don't get that response anymore
once you do it on regular basis the body
just goes oh we're here we are again
back to that ice thing
bring the buddy you know boost the
hormones bring all the blood no organs
you know that so but that cut that's
that's a similar thing to what you're
talking about in jujitsu where people
are the stress on the system they're
stressed and so they're involuntarily
you know and that's fight-or-flight one
thing you can really do to calm like
comic kid down this is the way you get
yourself into parasympathetic where you
bring your thing down is when you extend
your breath for seven seconds on the
inhale and the exhale that reduced
that'll bring everything down like if
you want to calm down and your or your
kids stret your little kids just all and
you get them to just breathe in for
seven seconds yeah and I tell people
think about a sigh my youngest daughter
when she would get upset she would do
that should I try you gotta breathe you
gotta breathe calm dead seven seconds is
a magic number if they if you can extend
the breath for seven seconds and the
body goes
the parasympathetic and totally lights
that's what you do to like go to sleep
at night like if you're having a hard
time so there's a bunch of stuff to
learn about the breath which is amazing
I think the reason why the the breath
has always been so important to me is
this because of the ocean because you
know growing up when you almost drowned
you know a thousand times you you you
what air is important you get to know if
you just get to appreciate like there's
none down there and it's all up there
and so be cool down there and so when
you say you can get back well I'd
learned breath work because of Hicks and
Gracie I'm watching Hicks and Gracie
practice yoga is a friend you know yeah
you know that's that's the pranayama yes
yeah there's a name for yeah this way
you twist it yeah yeah he really sucks
his organs Yap in his son can do it
amazingly Kron can do it amazingly yeah
yeah it's super good for you well that
for the organs yeah and that the ability
to control your breath like that is so
critical when you're sparring so
critical to get oxygen these long
training sessions well for your life
yeah for your life anytime you're in the
stress if you can control your breath
that controls your heart rate yeah do
you ever do 30 seconds in 30 seconds out
you ever do that yeah just slow deep
breaths in slow deep breaths oh that's
an amazing exercise yeah well that's the
extension of that
that's parasympathetic that's bringing
it seven just the minimum amount but
whenever you go into any of those long
extended stuff and then and then those
breath holds anytime you hold the breath
then you get that co2 level and that's
what gives you the angst you know what's
interesting because you know Wims done
like some record breaking stuff and you
have that free diving stuff where where
they scrub oxygen you know where they
hyperventilate and scrub the co2 and get
that real low but you have to be careful
about shallow water blackout so we don't
really practice any of that stuff we do
more like a salt bike jump in the pool
and see how long you can hold your
breath and then it's and then and then
you know five 10 10 seconds is like
that's big-time 15 seconds you're like
wow that was amazing I'm maximum heart
rate how long can you hold your heart I
mean how long can you hold your breath
that's um that's a challenge so I keep
an assault bike right next to the pool
yeah
yeah just control you roll it into the
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah wow yeah
wow there's always another you know
twist to the pretzel